et cette semaine nous faisons un bond
dans l'histoire mélanie poker vous nous
emmenez à la renaissance pour assister à
un bal comme l'époque c'est ça ça se
passe ce week-end et c'est les élèves
des conservatoires de versailles et de
viroflay qui vous invite à danser comme
on a pu le faire il ya 500 ou 600 ans le
meilleur de balle ci sera frédéric
martin un violoniste alors ce balai
donnés par une quarantaine d'enfants des
deux conservatoires il y a les flûtistes
il ya des violonistes il ya des
clavecinistes on le voit à l'image et ce
sont les élèves de trois professeurs qui
alterneront de la danse et de la musique
ils sont tous issus des premiers cycles
du conservatoire leurs professeurs
voulait leur proposer une animation pour
leur faire comprendre notamment
l'importance du rythme c'est plutôt un
spectacle avec participation du public
parce que le bal est ouvert aux parents
aux amis aux frères et soeurs qui
souhaitent venir danser mais
également bien sûr à nos élèves puisque
soit ils sont en train de danser soit
ils sont en train de jouer sur scène
s'adresse aux amis à la famille mais les
curieux peuvent aussi venir s'asseoir
sur final ils sont ils seront même très
très content parce qu'en plus la salle
où va se dorer se dérouler le bal et il
a une capacité de 200 personnes
il faut pas être un musicien ou un
danseur aguerris ce bal est avant tout
un moyen de découvrir un héritage
musical français découvrir aussi qu'elle
danse était pratiquée à la con mais pas
seulement
il y aura des brandes l'allemande la
gavotte de la gaillarde et bien d'autres
et pour vous donner un petit aperçu de
ce qu'ils vont vous proposer un extrait
en rejeter enregistré lors d'une
répétition le morceau s'appelle le
branle de la torche et il date de 1712
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors petite précision ce n'est pas 1712
comme j'étais juste avancé 1612 et si
vous voulez vous laisser tenter
rendez vous le samedi 4 mars à la salle
dunoyer de ségonzac à viroflay
ça commence à 18h30 par contre une
réservation est nécessaire pour cela
rien de plus simple direction le site
internet qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
le ballet sur la page d'accueil à la
rubrique les rendez vous merci beaucoup
mais la nuit pour cette présentation si
vous vous sentez l'âme d'un noble le
temps d'une après-midi vous savez où
vous rendre